how to build self-confidence
self-confidence refers to a general
sense of trust in your ability to
control your life
or it might be more situation specific
having a healthy level of
self-confidence can help you become more
successful in your personal and
professional life
here are some ways you can increase your
self-confidence
stop comparing yourself to others
social comparison theory explains that
making comparisons is natural
but it isn't likely to help boost your
self-confidence
it may even have the opposite effect
if you're feeling envious of someone
else's life it's also helpful to
remember your own strengths and
successes
keep a gratitude journal to better
recall the areas in life where you are
blessed
this can help you focus on your own life
versus focusing on the lives of others
take care of your body
caring for yourself is important to
self-confidence
make sure you are getting what you need
to feel good about yourself and your
abilities
eating healthy exercising
meditation and proper sleep are some
self-care practices linked to higher
levels of sleep confidence
surround yourself with positive people
the people you spend time with can
influence your thoughts and attitudes
about yourself perhaps more than you
realize
so pay attention to how others make you
feel
surround yourself with people who love
you and want the best for you
seek out others who are positive and can
help build your confidence
self-confidence and a positive attitude
go hand in hand
set realistic goals
pursuing your goals often involves
failing several times until you figure
out what works
this can make you wonder if you have
what it takes to succeed
it can also leave you questioning how to
be more confident while still achieving
your dreams
the answer lies in setting realistic
goals
setting high reaching goals and failing
to achieve them has been found to damage
confidence levels
face your fears
stop putting things off until you feel
more self-confident like asking someone
on a date or applying for a promotion
one of the best ways to build your
confidence in these situations is by
facing your fears head-on
practice facing some of your fears that
stem from a lack of self-confidence
you might learn that being a little
anxious or making a few mistakes isn't
as bad as you thought
and each time you move forward you gain
more confidence in yourself